a lot of things can be beautiful
landscapes
faces
fine art or epic architecture stars in
the sky
or simply the reflection of the sun on
an empty bottle beauty is nothing
tangible it only exists in our heads as
a pleasant feeling
if we have to define it we perceive
something as beautiful if its color
shape form or proportion somehow are
appealing or delightful to us
beauty is a very human experience that's
been with us for millions of years
even our first tools were trimmed to a
symmetrical shape
researchers have tried to find practical
reasons why our ancestors invested the
time to make their tools look nice but
couldn't really identify any it seems
that early humans shaped their tools
into teardrops simply because they liked
them better that way
throughout our history the definition of
beauty has changed a lot ideals have
shifted or turned into their opposites
but beyond individual and contemporary
taste some things have never really gone
out of fashion
the golden ratio symmetry or fractal
patterns can be found in the art and
architecture of cultures from our
beginnings to today
humans seem to be in mysterious inherent
agreement about the beauty of certain
things
the patterns that keep coming up are all
rooted in nature
they became part of our biology because
they helped our ancestors survive
fractal patterns for example occur all
over nature in snail shells flower heads
waves or clouds
identifying and assessing these things
and phenomena correctly used to be vital
do those clouds mean rain will come soon
are these waters safe to swim through
can i eat this
another pervasive thing is symmetry in
nature it means everything is as it
should be stems and trees and leaves and
blossoms all grow symmetrically a deer
with impressive antlers is probably a
source of nutritious meat
a deformed wheat here may not be safe to
eat asymmetrical face is more likely to
belong to a healthy and fertile mating
partner
because symmetry is so common in fauna
and flora it's extremely familiar to our
brain
it helped our ancestors evaluate their
environment more easily and react
quickly to danger
things that help us survive activate the
reward center in our brain recognizing
signals of safety and nutrition trigger
nice feelings in us
so our sense of beauty probably evolved
from pattern recognition
but it goes way beyond that now humans
seem to have evolved an instinct for
beauty that is deeply hardwired into us
it remains even after other processes in
our brain stop working
alzheimer's patients were asked to rank
the beauty of several paintings
then the experiment was repeated two
weeks later the patients had long since
forgotten the paintings but still ranked
the beauty of the paintings in the same
order one could argue that this doesn't
say much so what if people stick to
their personal preferences
but other research has shown that we
have a sort of lowest common denominator
when it comes to beauty
in different experiments people were
asked to distinguish real from fake
abstract paintings some were originals
by mondrian and pollock that were
painted based on strict rules like
fractal patterns while the imitations
were not
the majority picked out the original
artworks
this worked with paintings from both
artists even though their styles are
very different
another experiment also used abstract
artworks but asked people to pick them
out among similar paintings made either
by children or animals again the test
subjects pointed out the legit paintings
whose patterns were carefully planned
and not random
so while we have a hard time pinning
down what beauty is or what it's based
on we somehow recognize it when we see
it
[Music]
humans don't navigate nature trying to
survive day by day anymore we left the
natural world behind and created our own
we made the objects that surround us the
things we wear and use and look at
as we spread over the planet and our
numbers grew we shaped a completely
man-made environment
in the process of doing so we often
neglected beauty in favor of
functionality cost or efficiency we
built rows and rows of concrete housing
blocks that nobody wants to live in we
have ugly underground subway stations
shabby public service buildings and
sprawling malls
one bland standardized box beside the
next humans don't like monotony eye
tracking software has shown that people
keep focusing on details and ornaments
of architecture while brushing quickly
over blank walls
and not only are they no fun to look at
they actually make us miserable
experiments with skin sensors showed
that looking at vast dull facades makes
us feel bored and uncomfortable
this kind of boredom has been linked to
raised heart rates and stress levels and
the opposite seems to be true too over
the last decades more and more studies
have found that surroundings that are
actually aesthetically pleasing to us
can improve our well-being our behavior
cognitive function and mood
our bodies and brains react measurably
and visibly to everything that surrounds
us
beauty in particular has such a strong
impact on our well-being that making
useful things beautiful can actually
make them better
in 2017 a hospital examined recovery
factors through observation and
interviews with patients and found that
visual art in their lounge areas made
them more comfortable and happier about
their stay in general
another study looked at how well
patients recovered in a hospital that
had two wards
a very old and rather ugly one and a
newly renovated ward to the researcher's
surprise the patients that stayed in the
new renovated environment needed less
pain medication and were released on
average two days earlier than patients
recovering in the old ward
more beautiful surroundings made them
feel better physically
beauty also has an effect on us on a
daily basis it can improve our general
happiness
a study that looked at the main factors
influencing the happiness of adults
revealed an unexpected result besides
things like good health and a harmonious
family life individual happiness is
affected by how beautiful you find the
city you live in
beauty scored even higher than
cleanliness or safety
so what can we learn from all of this
we know that we humans have been
fine-tuned for millions of years to
process visual input and assess our
surroundings
it's just what we're programmed to do
and we're starting to learn more about
how much beauty as a property is really
influencing us beauty meets an inherent
need for meaningful information
maybe it would be worth giving it more
space in this man-made world we have
created
this video was a collaboration with the
creative agency zachmeister and walsh as
a contribution to their upcoming beauty
exhibition the exhibition will be shown
at the mark vienna from october 23rd
2018 until march 31st 2019 and the mark
frankfurt from may the first until
september 30th 2019
if you want to learn more about the
impact of beauty and see tons of
gorgeous installations and multimedia
objects go check it out
[Music]
[Music]
you